J'ai reçu un colis louche
les amis ce qui se passe est hyper excitant
j'ai reçu un mail de quelqu'un me disant
qu'il m'avait envoyé un colis
qui contient une escape-game
une escape-game normalement ça se passe dans une pièce
ok vous avez 1 heure pour euh... sortir de la pièce
là ça va être dans un putain  de colis
" On " va devoir aller chercher les indices dehors
pourquoi je dit  "on" parce que je vais pas faire ça seul
il m'a dit qu'il fallait que l'on soit trois
donc je vais faire appel aux deux meilleurs agents euh... de la planète
Mc fly et carlito
Musique enquêteur
Il y a vraiment un problème avec ton visage David vraiment
AH !!!
j’espère que je ne me suis pas trompé de colis
Si sa se trouve c'est un pack collector de Warner
Si sa se trouve c'est un...
Si sa ce trouve c'est un gode
Mais t'es trop original comme humoriste ou est-ce qu'on  peut te retrouvé?
Putain mais t'es chiant
Retrouvé moi au spectacle, tous les mardi dernier au 8 de la rue du même nom
Le spectacle c'est le nom de votre spectacle?
Exactement.
Ou le nom de la salle?
Les deux à la fois.
Alors.. Oh lalala
Putain mais si sa se trouve c'est une bombe, j'ai vraiment peur en vrai que sa nous explose à la gueule et que le mec soit un hater
Rire de Squeezie
Ok les mecs les mecs, c'est vraiment une escape game, c'est incroyable
Cri de Mcfly
Normalement ya une clé USB.. quelque part
Oh les mecs j'ai trouvé la clé USB!
Yeaaah
(voix de robot) Glissez la dans le processeur afin d'avoir les informations nécessaire ..
La clé USB est branchée les mecs
Bonjour messieurs, mon nom est nobody vie , je suis un agent du SCP et je serais votre instructeur lors de cette épreuve
Nous avons mis à votre disposition un colis et ceci est un rapport d'enquête envoyé par un agent de la SCP
Vous devez résoudre ce rapport. Si vous arrivez à résoudre l'ensemble du colis, vous remportez votre examen et j'aurais le plaisir de vous annoncez que vous êtes un agent du SCP
Squeezie: Ok les gars
Mcfly: sa serait trop bien
Je vous rappelle que c'est une épreuve intellectuelle
Il est interdit de faire usage de la force
Par contre, il est possible d'utiliser une navigation internet
N'oubliez pas de vous munir de votre dés.
Ceci est l'enseigne officielle des agents du SCP
Carlito: Le dés est là!
C'est moi qui l'ai trouvé putain
On se retrouvera à la prochaine étape une fois que vous aurez trouvé ceci. Bon courage.
Donc on a deux coffres avec cadenas.
McFly: On a aussi une carte mère.
Rapport d'enquête: Cela fait plusieurs jours que j'enquête en solitaire sur des apparitions paranormales.
Une entité qui n'était jusqu'à présent qu'un simple jeu vidéo, semble avoir pris vie plusieurs témoignages